Professor David Swensen:
Let me start out by
putting what I think is a
relatively controversial
proposition on the table and
that's that this investment
management business,
when stripped down to its bare
essentials, is really quite
simple.
Now, why do I say that?
Well, I think if we took the
group here today and divided you
up into smaller groups of four,
or five, or six and asked you
to talk about what's really
important in managing a
portfolio that has a very long
time horizon,
I think that almost all the
groups would come to very
similar conclusions.
If you're investing with a long
time horizon,
having an equity bias makes
sense;
stocks go up in the long run.
Bob Shiller's friend,
Jeremy Siegel,
wrote a book that has the very
simple title,
Stocks For The Long Run.
Well, the book is assigned;
you all know it.
The other thing that I think
would come out of the
discussions is that
diversification is important.
Anybody whose read a basic
finance text,
as a matter of fact,
I think anybody who thinks
about investments in a common
sense fashion knows that
diversification is an important
fundamental tenet of portfolio
management.
As a matter of fact,
Harry Markowitz called
diversification a "free lunch."
We spend all our time in intro.
econ.
figuring out there is no such
thing as a free lunch but
Markowitz tells us that
diversification is a free lunch.
For any given level of return,
you can reduce--For any given
level of risk,
you can increase the return;
sounds pretty good.
That's pretty simple, right?
Two tenets, an equity bias for
portfolios with a long time
horizon and diversification.
Bob mentioned in his
introduction that I showed up at
Yale in 1985,
after having spent six years on
Wall Street,
and I was totally unencumbered
by any portfolio management
experience.
I thought that was pretty neat.
Here I was, back at Yale,
with a billion dollar
portfolio--it seemed like a lot
of money at the time--no
portfolio management experience.
What do I do?
Well, one of the things I think
is a sensible thing to do in
life is look around at what
others are doing,
so I looked at what colleges
and universities had done in
terms of asset allocation.
Turns out that 50% of endowment
assets in the mid-1980s were
invested in common stocks,
40% of endowment assets were in
U.S.
bonds and U.S.
cash, and 10% in a smattering
of alternatives.
Well, I looked at that and I
thought, this doesn't really
make a lot of sense.
You have half of your assets in
one single asset class:
U.S.
common stocks.
You've got another 40% of your
assets in U.S.
bonds and cash.
So 90% of your portfolio is in
domestic marketable securities
and only 10% is invested in
things like real estate or
venture capital or private
equity--hardly enough to make a
difference in terms of the
portfolios returns.
Unencumbered by,
I guess, the conventional
wisdom, we started out at Yale
on a path that I think
is--fundamentally that changed
the way that institutions manage
portfolios.
A few years ago,
I wrote a book called
Pioneering Portfolio
Management.
The reason you could put an
audacious title like
Pioneering Portfolio
Management on the cover of
the book was that we moved away
from this traditional model with
50% in stocks and 40% in bonds
and cash to something that was
much more equity-oriented and
much more diversified.
What I'd like to do today is
talk to you about how it is that
we moved from this old model to
what it is that today many
institutions call the Yale
model.
The way that I would like to
talk about this journey that we
took is by looking at the tools
that we have available to us as
investors--these tools are the
same tools that we have whether
we're operating as individual
investors or institutional
investors--and describe how we
employ those tools at Yale and
how they led us to the portfolio
that we have today.
Those three tools are asset
allocation, market timing,
and security selection.
The first, asset allocation,
basically deals with which
assets you have in your
portfolio and in which
proportion you hold each of
those assets.
The second, market timing,
deals with short-term
deviations from the long-term
asset allocations that you
establish.
And the third,
securities selection,
speaks to how it is you manage
each of your individual asset
classes.
Are you going to hold the
market portfolio,
index your assets,
match the markets results?
Or are you going to manage each
individual asset class actively,
trying to beat the market and
generate risk-adjusted excess
returns?
Let's start out with the first:
asset allocation.
I think it's pretty widely
known that asset allocation is
far and away the most important
tool that we have available to
us as investors.
As a matter of fact,
it's so widely believed that
asset allocation is the most
important tool that I think some
people have come to the
conclusion that it's some sort
of law of finance that asset
allocation is the most important
tool.
It turns out that it's not a
financial law that asset
allocation takes center stage;
it really is more a description
of how it is that we behave.
Yale actually has a lot more
than the billion dollars that we
started with in 1985.
I think the estimate sheet that
I got yesterday morning said
that we've got about $22.5
billion dollars;
so that's been a nice run.
If I went back to my office
after speaking with you this
morning and took Yale's $22.5
billion dollars and put all of
it into Google stock,
asset allocation would have
very little to say about what
Yale's returns would be.
As a matter of fact,
security selection would
absolutely dominate the results.
The idiosyncratic behavior of
Google stock from the time that
we purchase it to the time that
we sell it would define Yale's
returns.
Alternatively,
if I went back to the office
and took Yale's $22.5 billion
dollars and decided that I was
going to day trade bond futures,
security selection wouldn't
have anything to say about the
returns;
asset allocation wouldn't have
anything to say about the
returns.
The returns would be
attributable solely to my
ability to market time the bond
futures market.
Now, I'm not going to do either
one of those things.
I'm not going to put Yale's
entire portfolio in Google
stock, I'm not going to go back
and take Yale's entire portfolio
to day-trade bond futures;
in part, because it would be
bad for me personally.
I think I would be fired as
soon as people found out what it
was that I was doing with the
portfolio and,
overwhelmingly more important,
it would be bad for the
University.
It's not a rational thing to do.
What will happen is that Yale
will continue to hold a
relatively well-diversified
portfolio as defined by the
range of asset classes in which
it invests.
When you look at each of those
individual asset
classes--domestic equities,
foreign equities,
bonds, real assets,
absolute return and private
equity--each of those individual
asset classes is going to be
relatively well-diversified in
terms of exposures to individual
positions or individual
securities.
Because that's true,
then asset allocation ends up
being the overwhelmingly
important determinant of the
University's results.
Because we hold relatively
stable, relatively
well-diversified portfolios,
security selection turns out
not to be an important
determinant of returns for most
investors and market timing
turns out not to be an important
determinant of returns.
The last man standing is asset
allocation and that tends to
drive both institutional returns
and individual returns.
Roger Ibbotson,
who is a colleague of Bob
Shiller's and mine at the School
of Management,
has done a fair amount of work,
studying the relative
importance of these sources of
returns.
He's come to the conclusion
that over 90% of the variability
of returns in institutional
portfolios is attributable to
asset allocation and that's the
number that I think most people
hear cited when they are looking
at Roger Ibbotson's work.
I think one of the more
interesting and even simpler
concepts that comes out of his
study is that more than 100% of
returns are defined by asset
allocation.
Now, how can that be true?
How can asset allocation be
responsible for more than 100%
of investment returns?
Well, it can only be true if
security selection and market
timing detract from
institutional returns or
individual returns in the
aggregate.
Of course, if think about it,
as a community,
the investment community is
going to lose from security
selection decisions.
If security selection is a
zero-sum game,
the amount by which the winner
wins equals the amount by which
the loser loses--winners and
losers being defined by
performance after a security
selection that has been
made--well,
that sounds like a zero-sum
game.
But then, if you take into
account that you create market
impact when you trade,
that you pay commissions when
you trade and you frequently pay
advisors substantial amounts of
money--whether they're mutual
fund managers or institutional
fund managers--there's this
leakage from the system that
causes the active results for
the community as a whole to be
negative.
Absolutely the same thing is
true on the market timing front.
I mean, to the extent that
you're making these short-term
bets against your long-term
policy, it requires trading and
trading is expensive.
It's very expensive when you
take into account not only the
direct costs,
but also the costs that you pay
advisors to help you make these
decisions.
So, it's not surprising that
asset allocation explains more
than 100% of returns and that,
for the community as a whole,
market timing and security
selection are costly and lower
the community's aggregate
investment returns.
It's a little bit of a
digression, but one of the
things that I've witnessed over
the past twenty years is that
the leakage of the--the leakage
from the system in terms of the
returns that go to the owners of
capital--leakage has increased
enormously.
Think about the advent of hedge
funds--twenty or twenty-five
years ago, hedge funds were a
blip on the radar screen.
Today, they're a very important
part of the fund's management
framework.
Well, those hedge funds charge
enormously more than what a
standard manage or marketable
securities firm charges.
Well, that leakage--that 1.5%
or 2% that you pay your hedge
fund manager--plus the 20% of
profits really reduces the
amount of return that's
available for the owners of
capital.
This idea that the difference
between the returns that you
would get if you took your asset
allocation,
implemented passively,
and the actual results that the
active investors get--the gap
between those two numbers--is
becoming larger and larger over
time,
generating more and more
returns for the provider of
investment management services
and lower and lower returns for
those that are hiring those
external advisors.
To get back on track,
let's look at the basic
underpinnings to this notion
that asset allocation is at the
center of the investor's
decision-making process.
There are two points that we
talked about--the hypothetical
points that came out of the
small group discussions that I
suggested we might think about
at the beginning of this talk.
First, in terms of equity bias.
Now, we're going to go back to
Roger Ibbotson at the School of
Management.
He did some path breaking work
in terms of describing capital
markets returns over reasonably
long periods of time.
I guess you've already looked
at Stocks for the Long
Run;
you've seen 200 years worth of
data.
Roger Ibbotson's data goes back
to 1925 and these are the actual
numbers we used when we first
started doing our mean-variance
optimization in our simulations,
trying to come to conclusions
about what the appropriate
allocations would be for Yale's
portfolio.
I'm sure you're familiar with
the drill--you put a dollar into
various asset classes,
in this case,
at the end of 1925 and hold
those asset classes for,
in this case,
eighty-one years;
the numbers go through the end
of 2006.
As you put a dollar in treasury
bills, you end up with a
nineteen multiple;
that sounds pretty good.
You get nineteen times your
money over eighty-one years,
but then if you take into
account the inflation consumes a
multiple of eleven and you're an
institution like Yale that
consumes only,
after inflation returns,
putting your money into
treasury bills really didn't get
you very much.
Suppose you step out in the
risk spectrum and put a dollar
into the bond market.
Over that eighty-one year
period you would have gotten a
multiple of seventy-two.
Well, now we're talking some
real after inflation returns
that can be umed.
But, when you move from lending
money to the government--either
short-term with bills or longer
term with bonds--to investing in
the equity market,
there's a stunning difference
in terms of the returns.
Just by putting money into a
broadly diversified portfolio of
stocks you would have gotten
3,077 times your money.
If you would have stepped
further out of the risk spectrum
and put your money into a
portfolio of small stocks you
would have gotten 15,922 times
your money.
So, ownership of stocks
absolutely crushes buying
bonds--almost 16,000 times your
money or more than 3,000 times
your money in the stock market
as opposed to 72 times your
money or 19 times your money in
the bond market or the bill
market.
It almost makes you wonder
whether this diversification
thing makes any sense.
I mean, why would you do that?
Why would you put any of your
assets in bonds if stocks are
going to give you 16,000 times
your money?
That bond multiple of 72 is
just a drag on returns--what's
the point?
This question,
particularly in the late 1980s,
was very important to me
personally because we were
trying to put together a
sensible portfolio for Yale and
if that sensible portfolio just
involved identifying the
high-risk asset class and
putting all your assets into,
let's say, small stocks,
it wouldn't take the investment
committee very long to figure
out that they didn't need to pay
me to do that;
they could do that on their own.
And if they didn't need to pay
me, then I wouldn't have any
income to put food on the table
for my wife and children.
So, there had to be more to it
than just identifying the
high-risk asset class and
putting your assets there and
letting it rip.
I went back and took a closer
look at Roger Ibbotson's data
and there are lots of examples
that will illustrate this point,
but the most dramatic occurs
around the crash in October
1929.
For every dollar that you had
in small stocks at the peak of
the market, by the end of 1929,
you lost 54% of your money.
By the end of 1930,
you lost another 38% of your
money;
by the end of 1931,
you lost another 50%;
and by the end of--by June of
1932, you lost another 32%.
So, for every dollar that you
had at the peak,
at the trough you had $.10
left.
At some point,
when your dollars were turning
into dimes, you'd say,
forget this,
this is ridiculous,
it doesn't make any sense for
me to own these risky small-cap
stocks.
And you would sell your small
stocks and put your money where?
Either in treasury bonds or
treasury bills.
And of course,
that's what the overwhelming
portion of the investment
community did in the 1930s,
and in the 1940s,
and in the 1950s.
As long as there was a memory
of the searing experience that
people had in the equity markets
around the time of the great
crash,
people reacted to it by saying,
avoid this risky asset,
it doesn't make any sense for a
fiduciary or for an individual
to own these risky things called
stocks.
As a matter of fact,
I was looking at some of the
contemporary literature,
the popular literature,
and there was an article in the
Saturday Evening Post that
basically said,
you shouldn't call stocks
securities--that was a
ridiculous thing to call them;
they should be called
insecurities because they were
so risky.
Of course, this attitude came
at exactly the wrong time.
If you put a dollar into small
stocks in June of 1932,
by the end of 2006,
you would have had 159,000
times your money.
Just at the point of maximum
opportunity people were at the
point of maximum bearishness
about the equity markets.
The take-aways are that an
equity bias is an absolutely
sensible underpinning for
investors with long time
horizons but that
diversification is important.
You have to limit your exposure
to risky asset classes to a
level that allows you to sustain
those positions even in the face
of terribly adverse market
conditions.
Let's move to the second point:
market timing.
I actually have a quotation
here.
A few months ago,
some former students of
mine--former colleagues of
mine--gave this very nice party
at the Yale Club.
I used to teach a big lecture
class when I first got to Yale
in the late 1980s and my last
lecture always involved taking
Keynes's General Theory,
and quoting from what I think
is Keynes--is one of the most
wonderful writers about issues
surrounding investment
management.
This particular copy was pretty
dog-eared;
as a matter of fact,
it was a paperback copy and I
think it was in about eight or
ten different pieces and the
people that threw this party
remembered that,
so they gave me it at this
celebration.
It made me wonder if they were
trying to tell that I should
retire;
it felt like a retirement party.
I feel like I'm way too young
to retire.
But as a gift,
they gave me a first edition of
Keynes's General Theory.
I was coming back to New Haven
on the train afterwards and I
came across this quote.
Keynes wrote that,
"The idea of wholesale shifts
is for various reasons
impracticable and indeed
undesirable.
Most of those who attempt to
sell too late and buy too late
and do both too often,
incurring heavy expenses and
developing too unsettled and
speculative state of mind."
He's absolutely right.
I wrote my first book--I
already talked about that,
Pioneering Portfolio
Management--that deals with
the challenges that face
institutional investors.
Subsequently,
I wrote a book called
Unconventional Success
that deals with individual
investors.
In Unconventional
Success, I did a study of
individual behavior in their
mutual fund purchases and sales
around the collapse of the
Internet bubble in March of
2000.
What I did was I took the ten
best-performing Internet funds
and looked at the returns from
1997 to 2002.
Now this is,
I think, a surprising starting
point.
If you look at the ten
best-performing Internet funds
from 1997 to 2002,
the time-weighted return is
1.5% per year positive,
so the funds went way up and
then they went way down.
But it's positive 1.5% per
year, time-weighted--that's the
number that you see in the
prospectus or the number that
you see in the
advertisements--so you say,
what's the big deal,
no harm no foul.
Well, there's another way to
look at returns--those are the
dollar-weighted returns--and the
dollar-weighted returns actually
do a better job of describing
the experience of the group of
investors that participated in
these funds.
Dollar-weighted obviously takes
into account when the cash flows
come in and when they go out.
When you do the dollar-weighted
returns, you find out that there
was $13.7 billion invested in
these funds and the investors
lost $9.9 billion out of the
13.7 that they committed;
so, 72% of the money that was
invested in these funds was
lost.
Because of the way that we deal
with taxes and mutual funds,
you can get a tax bill for
gains that were realized by the
investment manager turning over
the portfolio even though you
might not have held the shares
during the period when the gains
were realized.
So, in addition to losing $9.9
billion, there were capital
gains' distributions of $3.3
billion dollars representing
about 24% of the money that was
invested.
So, adding insult to injury,
you lost 72% of the money and
then you got a tax bill for 24%
of the amount that had been put
in;
not a very happy experience.
After I wrote the book,
Morningstar did a much more
comprehensive study of every
single one of the equity
categories that they follow.
There were seventeen categories
of equity mutual funds and they
compared the dollar-weighted to
the time-weighted returns.
In every one of those seventeen
categories, the dollar-weighted
returns were less than the
time-weighted returns.
Well, how does that happen?
The same way that these
investors and the Internet tech
funds lost their money.
They bought after the funds had
gone up and they sold after they
had gone down.
When you buy high and sell low
it's really hard to generate
returns, even if you do it with
great enthusiasm and great
volume.
The Morningstar study is
incredibly damning in terms of
the market timing abilities of
individual investors.
Systematically,
investors are buying after
things have gone up,
selling after they've gone
down,
and the problem is most severe
in those funds that show the
greatest volatility.
The gap in what Morningstar
calls the "conservative
allocation fund" is .3% per
year.
Now, that's not a huge number
but, obviously,
when you're hoping to beat the
market by a point or two,
losing by .3% per year because
of your market timing inability
is a bad thing.
But if you look at the tech
fund category,
the difference between the
dollar-weighted and the
time-weighted returns--this is
over a ten-year period--is 13.4%
per annum;
that's stunning.
Compound that 13.4% over ten
years and there's just an
enormous gap between those
mutual fund numbers that are in
the prospectus and in the
advertisement--the time-weighted
returns and the dollar-weighted
returns that talk about the
actual experience of the
investment community.
I'm not just going to pick on
individual investors,
I'm going to pick on
institutional investors too.
One of the studies that I did
for my first book,
Pioneering Portfolio
Management,
looked at the behavior of
endowments and foundations
around the crash in October
1987.
I used to talk about the crash
in October 1987 without
explaining what it was and I do
still teach a seminar in the
economics department in the
Fall.
I started talking about what
happened in October 1987 and I
looked around the room and I
realized that I think the
students were three or four
years old in 1987 and weren't
yet reading The Wall Street
Journal.
So, just to give you a little
bit of context,
the crash was really an
extraordinary event.
According to my calculations it
was a twenty-five standard
deviation event.
One standard deviation happens
one draw out of three,
two standard deviations one out
of twenty, three standard
deviations is one out of one
hundred.
An eight standard deviation
event happens once out of every
six trillion trials.
You can't come up with a number
to describe the twenty-five
standard deviation event;
it's just too large a number,
I think, for any of us to
really comprehend.
In essence, this collapse in
stock prices--the one-day
collapse in stock prices--I
think in the U.S.
the price was,
depending on which index you
were looking at,
were down 21-22% in a single
day.
Interestingly,
most major markets around the
world were off by a similar
magnitude.
This one-day collapse in stock
prices was a virtual
impossibility.
Of course, this was just a
change in stock prices;
it wasn't related to any
fundamental change in the
economy or any fundamental
change in corporate prospects.
It was just a financial event.
If stock prices went down--by
the way, bond prices went up.
When people were selling
stocks, money had to go
somewhere.
Well, it went into the bond
market.
There was a huge rally in
treasury bonds on October
19,1987.
So, stocks were cheaper and
bonds were more expensive.
Well, what do you do?
You buy what's cheap and sell
what's expensive.
But what did endowments and
foundations do?
Well, if you look at the annual
reports of their asset
allocation, in June of 1987,
their equity allocation was
higher than it had been for
fifteen years.
The '70s were a terrible time
to invest in stocks,
a bull market had started in
1982.
We were five years into this
bull market and people were
getting excited about the fact
that stocks were going up and
equity allocations were at a
fifteen-year high.
Of course, the money had to
come from somewhere,
so bond allocations were at a
fifteen-year low.
Fast forward to June 30,1988
and stock allocations had
dropped and, not only had they
dropped,
they dropped by more than the
decline in stock prices
associated with this collapse in
October 19,1987.
Bond allocations had increased
by more than could be explained
by the increase in bond prices
over the course of the year.
The only conclusion that you
could draw is these supposedly
sophisticated institutional
investors sold stocks in
November and December and
January because they were
fearful and they bought bonds in
October,
November, and December--maybe
because they were fearful or
maybe because they were greedy.
Emotion ruled the decisions,
not rational economic calculus.
The costs were huge--not just
the immediate costs in terms of
the move from stocks to bonds.
It took these institutions
until 1993--a full six years--to
get their bond allocation back
down to where it had been prior
to the crash in October 1987.
And this is in the context of
one of the greatest bull markets
ever.
You certainly have to measure
the bull market,
from 1982 to 2000 and some
people would say that 2000 was
just a blip and we're still in
this bull market.
But regardless of how you
measure it, for a full
half-dozen years,
in the midst of this bull
market,
colleges and universities were
over-allocated to fixed income
relative to where they had been
in June of 1987.
The take-away is to avoid
market timing.
The underlying driving force
behind market timing decisions
seems to be emotional--fear,
greed, chasing
performance--buying something
after it has gone up,
disappointment,
and sales after something has
declined.
As opposed to rationally
stepping up when something
appears relatively attractive
and overweighting and then
leaning against the wind by
selling something that's
performed well.
Final source of
returns--security selection.
We've already talked about how
security selection is a zero-sum
game.
The only way that somebody can
overweight Ford Motor Company in
the market is to have somebody
have a counter position where
they underweight Ford Motor
Company;
only one of those is going to
be right.
It's measured by subsequent
performance in the amount by
which the winner wins equals the
amount by which the loser loses,
but it costs a lot to play the
game.
As a matter of fact,
it costs an increasing amount
to play the game when you look
at the fees that are paid to
investment managers and hedge
funds.
So, after taking into account
the market impact,
and the commissions,
and the fees,
this zero-sum game becomes a
negative-sum game.
When you look at the returns
for institutions,
you see exactly what it is that
you'd expect.
Here's ten years worth of data
from the Frank Russell
Corporation, the benchmark
Wilshire 5000.
For the ten years ended June
30,2005, it returned 9.9% per
year and then the average return
for the actively managed equity
fund was 9.6% per year,
so we're back to that thirty
basis points.
Maybe on average institutions
lose thirty basis points,
but it's kind of Lake Wobegon,
where we all believe that we're
better than average,
so we're going to overcome that
thirty basis points--that's not
such a big hurdle.
There's a very important
phenomenon that you need to take
into account when you look at
these histories of returns that
are generated by active
managers.
This is true whether you look
at the universe of the mutual
fund managers that we might have
available to us as individuals
or whether it's institutional
data,
such as those that I just cited;
that concept is survivorship
bias.
The only numbers that appear
for the trailing ten years are
numbers that are associated with
firms that are still in
business.
There were probably a number of
firms that, over that ten-year
period, went out of business.
Now, which firms do you think
went out of business?
Not the ones that are producing
great results.
The problem is even more severe
when you're looking at mutual
funds because there's kind of a
cynical game that mutual fund
management companies play.
If they have an underperforming
fund, sometimes they allow it to
die a dignified death;
although, that doesn't happen
very often.
What they usually do is they
take the underperforming fund
and they merge it with one that
has a better track record.
All of a sudden the
underperforming fund's record
disappears and the assets are in
a fund that has a better
record--a record that you can
actually market.
Then when we look at the
statistics, all we see are a lot
of assets in the fund that
performed well and the
underperforming fund that was
merged out of existence isn't
there anymore.
How important is this
survivorship bias?
If you look at the Frank
Russell data--and I just cited
ten-year returns ending June
30,2005, so that period started
in 1996--well,
in 1996 there were 307 managers
that reported returns.
By the time 2005 rolled around,
there were only 177 managers
that reported returns,
so 130 managers disappeared.
Now, more than 130 managers
failed because,
in addition to survivorship
bias, there's something called
backfill bias.
That's when a new manager
appears subsequent to the
beginning of the ten-year
period;
they'll put not only the new
numbers in, but they'll take the
history of the new manager and
put that history into the
database.
Which direction is that going
to move the numbers?
Well, that's going to inflate
the numbers too because the only
managers that kind of raise
their hand and say,
hey I've got this interesting
new approach to managing
domestic equities--or whatever
the asset class is--are the ones
that have succeeded.
You've got survivorship bias
taking out bad records and then
you've got backfill bias adding
good records.
They both cause the universe of
active management returns to
appear to be better than the
reality because there's a lot in
there that doesn't have anything
to do with the average
experience of,
in this case,
an institutional investor.
Sometimes the numbers can be
pretty dramatic;
I mean, 2000 was a year of
great flux in the markets
because that's when the Internet
bubble burst.
If you looked at the domestic
equity return--the average
return that was posted in
2000--it was -3.1%.
Then if you fast forward to
2005 and look at the average
return that was posted for 2000,
it was +1.2%.
So, the combination of
survivorship bias and backfill
bias for that one year made 4.3
percentage points difference.
As reported contemporaneously
in 2000, the number was -3.1%
but if you look at the number
reported for 2005,
because bad records had
disappeared and good records had
been added, all of a sudden the
average experience for that year
went up to +1.2%.
This is incredibly important
because, when you look at this
number that we started out with,
saying the benchmark was 9.9
but net of fees the managers on
average only lost thirty basis
points--or .3%--you'd say,
well that's a game I don't mind
playing.
Then if you adjust for
survivorship bias,
you end up concluding that the
deficit wasn't .3% but the
deficit was actually 2%.
In a world where,
if you could win by a
percentage point or two relative
to the market,
to have the average be minus
two full percentage points is
pretty daunting.
That's the kind of issue with
survivorship bias and backfill
bias in the relatively
established asset class of
domestic equities.
The problem is even more severe
when you look at something
that's relatively new,
like the hedge fund world.
Now, why is that?
Well, if hedge funds first
became mainstream maybe fifteen
years ago, then what are you
looking at in terms of history?
The only history that you would
have had fifteen years ago would
have been those funds that
produced great returns,
so it's all identified after
the fact.
At least in the domestic equity
world you've got a pretty stable
base that you were looking at
ten years ago,
so the survivorship bias and
the backfill bias would be much,
much more of a problem in the
hedge fund world.
Burt Malkiel who wrote a book
called A Random Walk Down
Wall Street,
which if it's not on your
reading list you ought to pick
up and take a look at because
it's really fun to read but it's
also extremely insightful,
took a look at survivorship
bias and backfill bias in the
hedge fund world.
He looked at a group of hedge
funds that numbered 331 in 1996
and by 2004, eight years later,
75% of them had disappeared.
Looking at this particular
group, he estimated survivorship
bias to be 4.4% per year and
backfill bias to be 7.3% per
year.
So, we're talking about a group
of funds that in aggregate
probably produced somewhere in
the low teens returns and he's
got 11.7% per year combined
survivorship bias and backfill
bias.
Roger Ibbotson took a look at a
larger group of
funds--3,500--funds over a
ten-year period and found
survivorship bias at 2.9% per
year and backfill bias at 4.6%
per year.
So, huge amounts of
institutional funds and
individual funds are going into
this hedge fund world.
You look at the returns that
are reported for hedge funds in
aggregate--they're generally
12%, 13%, 14% per year for the
last five or ten years.
In the case of Burt Malkiel's
data, more than 11% per year and
in the case of Roger Ibbotson's
data,
between 7% and 8% per year of
those returns can be explained
either by backfill bias or
survivorship bias.
If you subtract those numbers
from the reported numbers,
the returns that the investors
that were actually investing in
the funds that are defined as
part of the universe at the time
are low,
maybe mid-single digits--far
less than people would expect
for the amount of risk that
they're taking to be exposed to
this particular group of active
managers.
The final point that I want to
make with respect to security
selection actually is a little
bit different.
It has to do with the degree of
opportunity.
This is once you've decided
that you're going to be an
active manager and try and
pursue market beating
strategies,
how do you decide where it is
that you want to spend your time
and energy?
Now, I think it's logical that
if you're going to try and beat
the markets, you'd want to beat
the markets where the
opportunity was greatest.
Where's the opportunity
greatest?
The opportunity's greatest
where assets are least
efficiently priced.
How do you figure out where
things are least efficiently
priced?
Well unfortunately,
financial economists don't have
any direct measures of market
efficiency,
but I think there's a story
that you can tell about groups
of active manager returns that
will help point you toward those
asset classes that are least
efficiently priced.
If an asset class has
constituents that are
efficiently priced,
then it's very hard to generate
excess returns.
As a matter of fact,
if things were perfectly
efficiently priced,
there wouldn't be any
opportunity to generate excess
returns and if you make active
bets--if you make bets against
the market--then whether you win
or lose has to do with luck.
How are managers going to
behave in an asset class where
things are efficiently priced?
Well, they're not going to make
big bets, right?
If they do make big bets maybe
they get lucky once,
or twice, or three times,
but ultimately their luck is
going to run out.
And when their luck runs out,
they'll post bad results and
get fired.
How do you stay in business?
You stay in business by looking
a lot like the market.
What market might be
efficiently priced?
The bond markets,
in general, and the
high-quality bonds in particular
are probably easiest to value.
It's all about math.
The government bond,
you don't have to worry about
default.
Generally, you don't have to
worry about optionality or call
provisions and so it's math.
You're given coupon payments
every six months and then,
when the bond matures,
you get your money back.
So there's not a lot of room in
the government bond market or
other high-quality bond markets
to generate excess returns.
How about the other end of the
spectrum?
The other end of the spectrum
is a market that is very hard to
define.
As a matter of fact,
there might not even be a
benchmark against which you can
measure results and you'd think
about the venture capital world.
How do you hug the market in
the venture capital world?
You can't;
it's very idiosyncratic.
If you're doing early-stage
venture investing,
you're backing entrepreneurs
and ideas and they're operating
out of their garage.
I mean, this romantic notion of
what goes on in Silicon Valley
actually still holds true in a
lot of cases but there's
absolutely no way,
as a venture capital investor,
you could index the venture
capital market.
If you look at the behavior of
groups of active managers and
the dispersion of returns,
I think it gives you some idea
of what the efficiency is with
which assets in these individual
assets classes are priced.
Just as I foreshadowed,
if you look at the difference
between the first and third
quartile in the bond
market--these are active returns
over a ten-year period,
again ending June 30,2005--and
the fixed income market,
the difference between first
and third quartile is a half a
percent per annum.
That's an incredibly tight
distribution of returns.
Half of the returns are within
a spread of a half-percent.
Then as you move out to the
equity markets where it's harder
to price things as
efficiently--large-cap
stocks--there are two-fold
percentage points,
first to third quartile.
Small-cap stocks are tougher to
price than large-cap stocks,
so there's a 4.7% differential,
first to third quartile.
The hedge fund world is 7.1%
first to third quartile,
real estate 9.3% per annum,
leveraged buyouts 13.7% per
annum--this is over a ten-year
period, so now we're starting to
talk about some pretty
significant dispersion.
Of course, in the venture
capital world,
the least efficiently priced of
all,
there's a 43.2% differential
between the top quartile and the
bottom quartile.
If I'm going to be active in
terms of managing my portfolio,
should I spend my time and
energy trying to beat the bond
market?
Where even if you can find
somebody who's going to be a
first quartile manager,
there's almost no difference
between the first quartile
return and the third quartile
return.
Or should I spend my time and
energy trying to find the top
quartile bond,
top quartile real estate
manager,
or buyout manager,
or venture capital manager?
I think the answer is pretty
obvious.
You want to spend your time and
energy pursuing the most
inefficiently priced asset
classes because there's an
enormous reward for identifying
the top quartile venture
capitalist and almost no reward
for being in the top quartile of
the high-quality bond universe.
The overall conclusions are
that, with respect to asset
allocation, you want to create
an equity-oriented diversified
portfolio.
With regard to market timing,
you don't want to do it.
And with respect to securities
selection, you want to consider
your skills and you want to
consider the efficiency of
markets when you're making your
decisions as to whether or not
to pursue passive management or
active management.
Where did this lead us in terms
of Yale's portfolio?
Our current portfolio has 11%
allocated to domestic equities,
15% to foreign equities,
and 4% to bonds,
so traditional marketable
securities account for 30% of
assets.
The absolute return portfolio,
which is a group of hedge funds
that strive to produce
fundamentally uncorrelated
returns, accounts for 23% of
assets;
our real assets portfolio,
which includes timber,
oil and gas,
and real estate,
amounts to 28% of the
portfolio;
and private equity,
which includes venture capital
and leveraged buyouts,
is 19% of assets.
So, 70% of the portfolio is in
absolute return,
real assets,
private equity,
alternatives--broadly defined.
If you take this portfolio and
apply the tests that we
articulated at the outset of the
lecture today--equity
orientation and
diversification--the portfolio
is clearly equity-oriented;
96% of assets are invested in
some type of vehicle that we
would expect to generate
equity-like returns over
reasonably long periods of time.
In terms of diversification,
there are half a dozen asset
classes with weights that range
between 4% and 28%.
So, if you just came down and
took a look at that and compared
it to 50% in domestic stocks,
40% in domestic bonds and cash,
and 10% in a smattering of
alternatives,
you'd say that this is really a
much,
much better diversified
portfolio than the one with
which we started.
The results have been okay.
Over the past twenty years,
we've generated 15.6% per annum
return, but that headline number
obviously has a lot to do with
the equity orientation of the
portfolio but doesn't describe
the importance of the
diversification.
We've had no down years since
1987--1987 that was the crash in
October that I talked about
earlier.
In that year,
we were early on in terms of
diversifying the portfolio--we'd
only been working on that
program for two years--and even
so,
the negative return was less
than 1%, so it was a modest
negative return.
Probably a more important test
of the portfolio was what
happened around the collapse of
the Internet bubble in 2000.
In the year ending June 30,2001
and 2002, returns for
institutional investors were on
average negative in both of
those years and actually in
every year since 1987 Yale has
had positive returns.
The equity orientation drove
the returns but the
diversification allowed us to
deliver those returns in a
stable fashion,
which is incredibly important
for an institution like Yale
that requires a steady supply of
funds to finance its operations.
When I started in 1985,
the distribution to the
operating budget was $45
million.
That represented 10% of
revenues and that was the lowest
level for the entire
century--the entire twentieth
century--10% of revenues.
The amount that we're spending
for the year ending June 30,2008
is $843 million--that represents
37% of revenues--and we're
projecting expenditures for the
following year of $1.15 billion.
The results have been really
quite extraordinary.
My favorite way to measure the
results is actually to compare
what Yale achieved with what we
would have had if we would have
just experienced average returns
over the past twenty years.
The difference between the
average return for colleges and
universities and Yale's returns
has added $14.4 billion dollars
to the University's coffers.
Whether you measure it in terms
of dollars of value added or in
terms of returns,
Yale has the best record among
colleges and universities for
the past two decades.
So with that,
I'd be happy to take any
questions that you might have.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
The question is,
if a group of Yalies started a
hedge fund, what would they have
to do to convince me to invest
in them?
One of the things that we've
done over the years has been
open-minded about backing groups
that don't have traditional
investment credentials.
If you went to a corporate
pension plan or a state pension
manager, they'd have a very
bureaucratic process--probably a
fifty or hundred page
questionnaire that you had to
fill out,
you'd have to deal with
consultants, and you'd have to
have ten years or five years
worth of audited performance
statistics.
We tend to think that that's
not the richest pond within
which we should fish.
We think that the more
interesting investment
opportunities are kind of
outside of the mainstream with
more entrepreneurial firms and
ones that might have less
traditional backgrounds.
That said, we just don't take
flyers on people that we think
have interesting resumes;
we want to have a demonstrated
ability to operate in the
markets that the investment
management firm is suggesting
that we back.
I would say,
part of what we look at are
hard quantitative factors,
but probably more important
than the numbers are the soft
qualitative attributes.
It's almost like what you
looked for in a Boy Scout or a
Girl Scout.
You want people of high
integrity.
You want people of
unimpeachable character.
You want people that are smart,
incredibly hard-working.
And in the investment world,
you want somebody who's really
obsessed with the
markets--somebody who doesn't
define winning by getting as
rich as they possibly can
because,
if that's their goal,
there are all sorts of things
that they can do to get rich
that don't have anything to do
with generating investment
returns.
We want people who are
maniacally focused on beating
the markets, generating superior
investment returns.
That's an incredibly important
distinction because,
think about it,
if what you want to do is get
rich,
you can put together a
reasonable investment record and
then raise staggering amounts of
money.
Size is the enemy of
performance.
So that staggering amount of
money then impairs the fund
managers' ability to continue
generating excellent returns,
but they can stay in business
and collect the fees that they
get for having this huge pile of
money.
The type of manager we're
looking for is somebody who
strives to generate excellent
returns and they'll frequently
raise modest amounts of money
and close to new investors,
measuring their success by
beating the market not by
generating huge flows of fees
for themselves.
It's a combination of looking
at kind of objective attributes
and subjective characteristics
and finding people who
ultimately will be good partners
for the University.
Student: How has Yale's
endowment dealt with the falling
house prices?
You said, if we invest in real
estate [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
The question is how we've dealt
with decline in housing prices.
We don't have really much of
any direct exposure to
homebuilders or to the housing
industry.
Most of our real estate
exposure is
institutional--acquisitions of
office buildings--largely in
major markets--central business
districts.
So, you'd find Yale with
interests in office buildings in
New York, Washington D.C.,
Chicago, San Francisco,
Los Angeles,
some in secondary markets as
well, but predominantly in large
metropolitan downtown areas.
There are also some hotel
investments, retail properties,
smattering of industrial
properties--not a lot of
exposure to individual houses.
The only way that we would get
that occasionally would be
through some sort of
lot-financing activities,
but that's not something that
I've generally liked.
I don't think the housing
industry, in general,
is a good place to be because
of its, sometimes,
violent cyclicality.
We did have a large,
short position in subprime
mortgage-backed securities,
which has paid off enormously
for the University and really
helped protect assets in the
past nine months or a year.
I think that,
generally speaking--and Bob
Shiller can speak to this with a
lot more authority than I
can--this bubble was not
something that should have
surprised people.
I thought the University
positioned itself well to take
advantage of this really not
surprising collapse in housing
prices.
Isn't that market timing?
I mean, it all depends on your
perspective.
I think market timing,
as I've defined it,
has to do with short-term
deviations from your long-term
policy targets.
I mentioned that our domestic
equity target was 11%.
If I came to the office next
week and decided domestic stocks
were too high--I want to move
that target down to 8%--in the
way that I've described market
timing,
that would be a market timing
move and we're very careful not
to do that.
We establish these targets,
we review them once a year,
we don't make changes in many
years,
they're quite stable,
and when we do move them we
don't move them by a lot.
That doesn't mean that we don't
manage the portfolio actively.
So, if we see areas that are
particularly interesting,
we're more than happy to deploy
capital to take advantage of
what we think are cheap assets
or expensive assets.
We made a big bet against
Internet stocks in 1999 and 2000
that was very profitable for the
University.
As I mentioned,
there was a big bet that credit
spreads, both in mortgages and
in corporates,
were way too narrow in the past
couple of years and that--we
thought that if they were priced
rationally those spreads would
widen and we put ourselves in a
position to profit from that.
Today, we're looking at
opportunities in distressed
securities.
A lot of these loans that were
made in 2005 and 2006 and early
in 2007 were made at very,
very narrow spreads and there
are opportunities out there to
buy bank loans,
which are at the very top of
the capital structure,
that we believe will be money
good for prices in the '80s.
If it turns out that they're
money good, you get your
interest and you get $1 for
every $.85 that you invested in
a few years.
If markets offer us
opportunities,
we're more than happy to take
advantage of them.
So, we will make valuation bets.
We'll look at
things--sectors--say they're
cheap or expensive and exploit
the opportunity;
but at least in terms of how I
define market timing,
it wouldn't be included in
that--it wouldn't be included in
that definition.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
The first question is,
what's the beta of the Yale
portfolio?
That's not a way that we really
think about it,
but I do believe that the risk
level of the University's
portfolio is really quite low in
statistical terms--much lower
than the risk level that you'd
have if you had a traditional
portfolio dominated by
marketable securities.
The reason it's low is that we
do have, what I think is,
superior diversification and
that really lowers the
University's risk.
A lot of people look at Yale's
portfolio and say,
oh it's risky because you've
got venture capital and you've
got timber--we have all these
things that you might believe
are individually risky,
but part of the magic of
diversification is if you've got
things that are individually
risky but they're not well
correlated one to another,
the overall portfolio risk
level is quite low.
I believe that we have quite a
low risk portfolio.
The second part of the question
dealt with the changes in our
exposure to foreign assets and
that's an area that we've been
very interested in.
Our foreign exposure is not
limited to the marketable
security exposure,
which I cited as being 15% of
the fund,
but there's foreign exposure in
real estate, there's foreign
exposure in leverage buyouts,
there's foreign exposure in
venture capital.
It's something that permeates
the portfolio and,
I think, provides really
interesting investment
opportunities because a lot of
the foreign markets are less
efficiently priced than those
that you find in the U.S.
And I think the fact that our
foreign investments are
generally denominated in
currencies other than the dollar
is also attractive--a good
diversifying tool for the
university.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
The question was whether we were
looking to take more short
positions as the economy appears
to be moving into recession and
I guess the second part of the
question was how do you remain
bullish in this kind of
environment.
I think the best answer to that
is a quote from one of my
contemporaries,
who I think is one of the best
investment managers out there.
A guy named Seth Klarman,
who works at a fund in Boston
called Baupost,
said that what he does is
worries top-down and invests
bottom-up.
I read The Wall Street
Journal every morning and I
worry about the credit crisis,
and I worry about credit cards,
and I worry about auto loans,
and I worry about corporate
loans,
and I worry about the solvency
of the banking system,
and then I go to work and I try
and find the best opportunities
that I possibly can.
So, the worrying top-down helps
because you don't want to put
yourself in a position where
you're going to get hurt by some
adverse macro,
sectoral circumstance,
but there's no way that you can
take $22.5 billion dollars and
be in the markets when they're
attractive and out of the
markets when they're not
attractive.
So you just say,
okay fine, this is the macro
circumstance that we're dealing
with and we're going to do
absolutely the best job we can
identifying individual,
specific, bottom-up
opportunities to deploy the
funds.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
Well, I think one of the
questions---the question is how
can you successfully invest in a
market where,
I guess, people say you might
catch a falling knife.
You buy something that's down
30% but it's got another 50% to
go and I think it just has to do
with time horizon.
Particularly if you have a
value orientation,
you tend to buy things early.
If you bought them with a good,
sound, fundamental investment
case and prices are down from
where you made your purchase,
have enough dry powder so that
you can purchase some more at
the now lower price but have
enough confidence in your thesis
to be able to hold the position
through the decline and wait for
the markets to recognize the
value that you identified.
I think one of the most
pervasive problems in the
financial markets is investment
with too short a time horizon.
The fact that people look at
quarterly returns of mutual
funds is incredibly
dysfunctional.
I mean, there's no way that you
can expect somebody quarter in
and quarter out or month in and
month out to produce superior
returns.
There just aren't pricing
anomalies that are significant
that are going to resolve
themselves in a matter of months
or weeks and so it's a silly
game to play.
By extending your time horizon
to three years,
or four years,
or five years,
it opens up a whole host of
investment opportunities that
aren't available to people that
are playing this silly,
short-term game.
So, it's not a big deal to buy
something at a price that you
think is attractive,
have it go down 20,
or 30, or 40%;
that ought to be almost a
positive thing because you get a
chance to add to the position of
even lower prices,
as long as you're ultimately
right that sometime in the
three-, or four-,
or five-year time horizon you
have your investment thesis
proves out and you're ultimately
able to exit the position at a
profit.
Student: [inaudible]
Professor David Swensen:
The question is about housing
indexes.
I'll defer those to Bob
Shiller-- I couldn't answer a
question like that in front of
him.
Great, thank you very much.